the california attorney general is set
to investigate the police involved
shooting which claimed the life of a
teenager inside a store's dressing room
thursday the chief of the lapd calls the
death of the 14 year old girl in north
hollywood absolutely heartbreaking
police were firing at an assault suspect
who was also killed carter evans reports
the suspect entered into the business
the bizarre attack inside a burlington
coat factory began when security asked a
man to leave the store according to an
employee who asked not to be identified
and that's when it all escalated from
there he tried to start threatening the
security that he was going to start
throwing items she told our los angeles
station kcbs that she tried to help
customers escape the suspect was waiting
downstairs i had a customer in front of
me he when she was as soon as she
reached down he attacked her hit her
with the chain we needed re for a female
victim had trauma they also received
additional radio calls
from multiple people indicating that
there was a possible shooting in
progress
investigators say when officers saw the
suspect about to assault another person
they opened fire killing a units officer
needs help
fired
they later found a bullet hole in the
wall we went behind it it turned out to
be the dressing room inside 14 year old
valentina oriana peralta was dead from a
gunshot wound she was reportedly trying
on quinceanera dresses with her mother
preliminarily we believe that round was
an officer's round no gun was found on
the suspect these are tragic and
unfortunate sequence of events
lapd policy is to release body cam video
after a police shooting within 45 days
but in this case the chief has promised
to release the video by monday for cbs
this morning saturday carter evans los
angeles